let me pull up this uh this next story
we got this tweet from Daniel Turner he
says the elite flocked to Davos this
week on their private jets to lecture us
average folk on why we must give up our
gas powered cars by an imaginary
deadline in order to save the planet and
in the meantime Wyoming lawmakers
proposed ban on electric vehicle sales
well well that's something new I guess
what what is it what Wyoming wants to
ban electric cars a group of GOP Wyoming
state lawmakers want to end electric
vehicle sales by 2035 saying the move
will help Safeguard the oil and gas
Industries so I'm sure most of you all
have heard California Oregon and
Washington are moving to ban gas cars I
think California already did goes into
effect 2035. now Wyoming is doing the
opposite could you imagine you're in
Oregon and you're like I'm gonna start
I'm going to drive uh I'm gonna Drive
East and then you get into Wyoming and
you're in your electric car because you
don't have any gas cars and there's no
electric charging stations and you're
just like what do I do or you're in
Wyoming and you're like I'm gonna go
visit the coast you drive through you
take your gas car you drive in Oregon no
gas stations
yeah this is uh a thought when you're an
authoritarian like what California is
doing is an authoritarian act it's
government getting in the way of a
private Market demanding that you
transition to a certain Thing by a
certain time what happens is the other
side can play the same game I'm against
it Libertarians have the right idea let
the free market go but
wait wait wait Tim we have freedom of
movement in the future that's not
supposed to happen people have their own
cars that's not supposed to happen we're
supposed to rent cars and share them and
borrow them just like all the companies
that have World economic Forum board
members that are heavily invested in
them we're not supposed to be using cars
and having private property that's not a
part of the UN 2030 vision and not a
part of the vision that Klaus Schwab was
talking about years ago when he was
talking about uh pretty much making sure
that people cannot and will not be
owning cars a lot of major cities are
also making it very difficult to drive
cars New York City is one of them they
set up surveillance cameras everywhere
there's nearly 15
000 surveillance cameras all throughout
New York City speed cameras everywhere
you go over 25 miles an hour you get a
ticket right away build to you there's a
lot of people office getting their
license plate in New York City because
obviously you know people people make
mistakes it happens 25 is is not a very
high speed it's a very low speed people
make a lot of mistakes people are being
indebted there's no parking spots every
street is being closed down so you can't
even drive down there drive down most
streets so so we are seeing this 2030
U.N Klaus Schwab World economic Forum
Vision be implemented very slowly but
it's already happening in New York City
it's already going to be happening in
California where they're banning not
just electric car not just sorry gas
cars diesel cars lawn mowers
um even golf carts are now being banned
in California which again is just
absolutely insane and crazy and going
towards the vision of what Klaus Schwab
wants for you and not for what anyone
else really wants well look I I can
sympathize with Clash Royale because I'm
you know just imagine you're sitting
there you know you're you're in your
yacht hanging out with all your Rich
buddies and then you look up in the
distance and there's there's some middle
class dude and he's drinking a soda and
you're like what makes him think he's
entitled to the same drinks that I am
and you just desperately want to take
from him everything he owns and then
just put him into indentured servitude I
can totally understand why either why
they're mad right or just you know just
totally wipe them off the planet because
there's too many people in this world
that's also another thing that they're
also openly calling for but but making
them super poor uh is is a way of
helping you know make that process go a
lot faster so so these people are are
not just eugenicists they're also utter
freaking Hypocrites there's an estimated
1100 private jets at Davos this year
they quadrupled their private jet
emissions last year than the previous
year before that so these are
individuals who obviously live by a
different set of rules don't care about
the environment don't give a damn about
it this is just their PR words that
they're using to of course justify their
larger takeover of society which is
exactly the Hostile takeover that we're
going through right now all right then
he's not on the boat watching the guy
drink a Coke he's looking out his window
and seeing human beings in general
is that he's just he's just mad they're
there he's just flying on the private
jet being like there's too much open
land here we need we need to you know
Sheamus and I uh came up with a bit a
while ago about Bill Gates that we never
got around to making because we because
we could put it on YouTube it was
basically a gag about how like Bill
Gates is his day and it's like he's
driving down the street and he like he
pulls into a McDonald's and then he's
like oh I have the Big Mac with a large
fry and don't forget the ketchup and
then when you posted the drive through
the hand in the bag and he looks and he
goes there's no ketchup and it's just
like a series of things throughout the
day where he's he gets minor
inconveniences but like once he he's
really angry the woman knocks in the
window it's like oh forgot your ketchup
and gives him more and then he has an
app on his phone
we can't talk about it on YouTube but it
activates a certain thing
and people that wipes out Humanity oh
and so he's like sitting there staring
at his phone like ready to press the
button then she's like wait don't forget
the ketchup and then he's like oh oh
thank you and then he keeps doing it
just like the general idea is that these
people's real anger is not centered in
anything logical it's centered in just
like their their
emotions related to other people like
they just don't like other people so
they make up reasons to justify why
there should be less people
and then Common People Cheer them on I I
said I kind of made my own definition of
whoa because I actually think this is a
part of wokeism and I said woke is the
act of allowing an authority outside of
God to Define your morality and what the
the way they're able to get people to
cheer this nonsense on is the climate
gods are their woke or whatever the
climate whatever you want to make it and
you're you're cheering on your own
demise that's how powerful I think this
religion is yeah it's amazing it's like
uh when Disney did the Lemmings
documentary you know the story of that
no apparent like so they made this
documentary in the Lemmings all walk off
the cliff and then everyone believes
Lemmings commit ritualistic suicide they
don't apparently what they were doing
was they had like push brooms and stuff
and they were like shoving the animals
off the cliff and beating them and so
they were fleeing to their death and
they were like now fell men claim it
happened that's what it feels like a lot
with this world economic Forum stuff
they're destroying your life taking away
everything from you locking things down
then when you're miserable they say are
you miserable people it's because of
climate change yeah I mean all these
people having heart attacks is climate
change yeah yeah suddenly suddenly dying
suddenly from climate change you know
and so what we got you gotta do
something about it
yeah I think it's uh for you know
talking about it for common people I
think uh don't be alarmed I think we
will make it through this uh it might
not be the same future you look at a
generation from now 20 years from now we
might all have neural links two or well
one or two generations from now life's
gonna be fine people are still going to
have friends you might be controlled by
a central being or a government but I
think humans are survivors and life will
be different but in in the end uh it
will look dystopian to us could you
imagine somebody from like the 18th
century looking at what we're doing
right now they would be blown out of
their minds and I think it'll be the
same type of thing generation from now I
think if you took someone from like 1850
in any capacity and transported them
here the first thing they would do was
going would go on a violent Rampage
thinking that it was all satanists and
demons and stuff and that's what we're
that's where we we are now kind of right
we're looking at this stuff I said it's
an anti-god movement I'm still against
it I'm going to speak out against it
don't get me wrong but I think we're
kind of in that same place
I think the future is going to be AI I
like people will eventually cease to
exist in some capacity and ever like
we're already integrating ourselves into
the network with with Twitter and with
these apps and everything and Elon buys
Twitter surprise surprise it's a massive
neural net he also is running neural
link you combine these two things I mean
I think Elon Elon bought Twitter because
he wants to build a neural net he wants
connect people's brains to it and
Twitter is already the base component of
people injecting their thoughts into a
machine
next you just need to hook it to
people's brains it's there yeah one of
the clips that I also just saw recently
was Elon Musk a couple years ago saying
hey we need to we need to have a serious
conversation about the development of
artificial intelligence here we need to
seriously have some real regulations
here we need to stop doing what we're
doing and he's like no one's listening
and this is just continuing so there's
going to be a lot of implications
because of this and a lot of the most
powerful most Sinister people are at the
head head of these larger technological
advancements there's a reason Klaus
Schwab is calling for the fourth
Industrial Revolution and when he's
calling for that he's calling for of
course using technology for his own
personal benefit screwing everyone else
over and with the advancements I mean
we're seeing the possibility of human
beings living forever and for a certain
group of people to live forever there's
going to be a lot of other people that
are not going to be living forever or
won't be living at all and we have to
understand that there's this larger
trade-off that is being talked about
very seriously right now at the world
economic Forum to be fair though I mean
think about it if they invented the
immortality pill right now and maybe
they already did could they just give it
to every single person
well they're going to say what would
they what how would How would how would
How would how would you guys deal with
that right now let's say some alien came
to you and said here's a bottle of pills
easily replicable and it will make
anyone who ingests the pill one time
biologically immortal like you can still
be hit by a car but you won't age to
death
would you just be like okay everyone can
have it I would spread it yeah yeah I'd
want everyone to have it I mean what you
would see is centralized power obviously
trying to control it and not let
everybody have it I think but like all
the woke people getting it and all the
yeah the zombies and everything I'm very
much you know I'm against the wokism but
I will support your right to be woke
yeah so but I think the challenge is
there are some people that
there are some people who believe in
hard work personal responsibility
individual liberty Freedom Etc and there
are some people who think they're
entitled to everything and should take
from you even by force and so it's like
if I'm faced with being like should I
give the immortality pill to the
hard-working Freedom loving
individualist or the woke authoritarian
Psychopaths with guns I probably
wouldn't I'd probably just be like man
that's a tough call isn't it because
look we're not talking about killing
anybody no we're talking about granting
them you know extended or eternal life
certainly extended the question would be
would you give purified clean water to
all those people the people you hate as
well people you disagree with your
enemies would you if you had the
opportunity to give everyone else's to
clean water you wouldn't
yeah I don't think it's that simple I
think if we're looking at say like China
right now
and what they're doing to the uyghurs in
those camps and I'm supposed to be okay
with being like I'm gonna Overlook all
that evil stuff you're doing is give you
some really nice things to help you no I
think the opposite is true I think maybe
at the very least you can be like look
if I've got something you want you got
to stop torturing and raping those women
you agree to that maybe we'll talk but
I'm not going to give you whatever you
know what I mean
I think some tech is that it belongs to
all of us if we can if we can make that
happen yeah but an individual like Jared
Kushner who again very powerful and is
already making statements about possibly
living forever you think he's going to
be sharing that with the yemenis that he
of course brokered a deal with the Saudi
Arabians that he's bombing uh like do
you think he's going to be doing any of
that I don't I don't think that's a
tough question man it is a very tough
question because it's also an ethical
question it's also a question about our
existence here and it kind of changes it
and and it changes also our relationship
with God as well so there's a lot of
deeper philosophical implications here
that I think are worth debating and
talking about on a longer bigger
perspective that's why I don't have an
answer for it well let me let me ask the
audience my first knee-jerk reaction is
no absolutely not you wouldn't share
with everybody I I wouldn't want it to
exist but the problem is it is like a
gun and will the powerful people use it
to of course control Humanity but again
that also makes you less human though
you take away people's Humanity at the
same time so you're also a part of their
problem so there's a larger conundrum
here that uh yeah maybe maybe that maybe
that's a the gun thing is probably the
better analogy I suppose people have a
right to live maybe if you don't have to
give it to them like we don't just go
around defending people guys yeah
exactly but access to it should be made
available to those who want it yeah let
me know what you guys think in the in
the comments put a one if you don't
think everyone is deserving of
immortality put it too if you think
everyone should just be given no matter
what no matter their political opinion
yeah if the founding fathers were
writing the Constitution today I could
see them putting that in as uh you have
the right to I mean I wouldn't want to
live forever right I mean that takes
away from my Human Experience takes away
from all the beautiful moments that I
have here I don't want that the main
thing is it makes you not age so you
could always kill yourself but you just
won't it won't be taken from you I think
is the idea except for these tragic
accidents they're gonna be that's the
problem too is if people think they can
live forever if they're safe they're
going to become obsessive with keeping
their surroundings safe and and soft
Bill Gates would lose his ish if
everyone got a pill to live forever Bill
Gates would be
ah you'd freak out right now and then
start to doubling and tripling down on
all of his efforts that he's already
tripling and doubling this is what I
think is a large component of it there
was uh like 10 10 uh no this is 12 years
ago I saw Aubrey De Grace speak in
California you know yeah long hair dude
yeah he's a Citizens researcher and he
said that what did he say I'll
paraphrase it could spend a decade
that's this is 12 years ago someone who
was 45 today will live to be 1 000 years
old that's what he said not because
we're going to invent a pill in in the
next 30 Years that will make you live
for a thousand years but because every
year we develop new medical advancements
and our medical advancements progress
faster than a person ages so for
instance someone's 45 in 10 years they
start getting you know bad you know
arteries or whatever well in the 10
years time we've already figured out a
cure for that 10 years later he's got
macular degeneration it's hearing we've
already got a cure for that's been 20
years now he's 100 years old like you
know and he's got joint pains don't
worry we've already figured how to
restore collagen and so it's just going
to keep happening I actually think
looking at stem cells and stem cell
therapy
yo that stuff's scary crazy we we talked
about this on one of the members only
segments you can actually get stem cells
taken from the umbilical cord or from
your own skin or fat they only got to
take it from babies that was a big
concern back in the day it was like
they're taking you know from aborted
babies and stuff not even they can take
from your own skin or fat your own stem
cells multiply them inject them into
your body the stem cells will seek out
damaged tissues and restore them full
doesn't that when I saw that and watch
this video about it it freaked me out
because I'm like uh won't that just make
you like immortal
because if if you're given Fresh So
cells have a certain number of Divisions
as the telomeres break down
if if our understanding of size is
correct if they're giving you a fresh
fully young baby cell that bonds would
it not just have perfect complete you
know DNA that could replicate or
whatever
sounds too good to be true well there's
already there's already Elites getting
uh blood from young people and athletes
bro just just stem cell therapies eight
thousand bucks you call you call the
company and say you want stem cells and
exosomes fifteen thousand dollars and
they cut that I I bet that's what Joe
Biden's getting it's on its way to being
like 80 bucks but that's the question do
do the people that own the world or that
are trying to run the business of the
world do they want
100 300 you know seven billion people to
live for another 6 000 years so that
they can have 800 children each and then
we've got 900 billion people on earth
like I don't think that would start wars
because you're fighting over resources
at that point and cannibalism because
then at that point human bodies are just
mobile food sources thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time